بعد أشهر من صراعه مع
ضيق التنفس ، أدرك روبرت أن صبغه
كان خطأً
لأنني لم أستطع التنفس في الليل في
أكتوبر ، تم إدخاله إلى المستشفى
وتم تشخيص حالته بأنه يعاني من قصور القلب الحاد اللا تعويضي
في مستشفى ريتشارد روس للقلب في أوهايو.
65 عامًا هو
أول مريض في الولايات المتحدة يحصل على نوع جديد
من العلاج لأنه يمكنني في الواقع أن
أشعر بقلبي ينبض في صدري وهو
ما لم أتمكن من القيام به قبل
وضع قسطرة من خلال وريد في رقبته
وفي الداخل  قلب صبغ حيث
تم استخدام الأقطاب الكهربائية لتحفيز العصب
يقول الأطباء إن الدراسات المبكرة تظهر أن هذا يمكن أن يزيد من
قوة ضربات القلب لضخ المزيد من
الدم دون زيادة
معدل ضربات قلب المريض بشكل ملحوظ عن طريق زيادة
الكمية التي يقوم بها القلب بشكل طبيعي
يمكننا بعد ذلك البدء في الإصلاح
يستخدم قلبه الأدوية والعلاجات الأخرى
المتوفرة لدينا الدكتور سيدار
راميشاماني وفريقه يقومون
بإجراء فحص الصبغة أثناء العلاج.
لا يزال تناول الطعام قيد الدراسة ، يقول إن
هذا يمكن أن يكون خطوة كبيرة إلى الأمام في
مساعدة مرضى قصور القلب ،
العلاجات التقليدية ليست
مصممة جيدًا لزيادة كمية تدفق الدم
من
القلب ، فالزوجين الذين لدينا
لديهم الكثير من الآثار الجانبية  بعد أيام
من الإجراء قبل مغادرة
المستشفى ، يقول الصبغ إنه كان قادرًا
على الحصول على فرصة ومزيد من الوقت مع
حفيده من
أجل الصحة الدقيقة أنا ماندي غايثر